nous allons commencer euh notre audition
de ce jour et
euh nous recevons euh cet après-midi
Jean-Michel Blanquer ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale comme vous le
savez la commission des lois et la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication on lancé en en
juillet dernier une mission conjointe de
contrôle sur le signalement et le
traitement des pressions menaces et
agressions dont les enseignants sont
victimes
vous avez été monsieur le ministre vous
avez été ministre de l'éducation
nationale de 2017 à 2022 ce qui fait de
vous je tiens à le rappeler le Ministre
ayant occupé cette
fonction le plus longtemps sous la 5e
République et vous étiez également en
fonction au moment de l'assassinat de
Samuel pati et c'est à ce titre que nous
vous entendons aujourd'hui 3 ans après
euh les faits et 3 ans après votre
première audition sur ce sujet je vous
rappelle que nos travaux ne visent pas à
se pencher sur les faits eux-mêmes euh
et et je rappelle que ces faits
sont seront jugés font l'objet d'une
procédure de justice ils ne nous
appartient pas évidemment euh d'empiété
sur le travail de la justice en revanche
nous nous concentrons sur la définition
d'éventuelles procédures et de
garde-fous tendant à à permettre à
prévenir la répétition euh de ces drames
qui endeuille notre pays votre
témoignage bien sûr nous sera ainsi
précieux pour nous remémorer les mesures
que vous avez souhaité prendre à la
suite de l'assassinat de Samuel pati et
pour mesurer l'évolution des pressions
des menaces et des agressions constatées
à l'égard des enseignants au cours des
trois dernières années par ailleurs nous
avons récemment auditionné le Conseil
des Sages de la
léicité institution que vous avez créé
en janvier 2018 nous avons entendu à
cette occasion des propos fort forts les
ans craindre l'existence d'une rupture
générationnelle chez les enseignants
dans dans la défense ou la promotion de
la laïcité à l'école de de votre point
de vue comment faire pour que la défense
de la licité et les valeurs de de la
République fédère l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative enfin les les
témoignages d'enseignants que nous avons
pu recueillir montrre les difficultés
rencontrées par certains d'entre eux
pour obtenir le soutien de leur
hiérarchie face aux pressions aux
contestations ou aux insultes offéré par
des élèves ou aussi bien souvent par des
parents nous serions heureux d'entendre
votre analyse concernant l'évolution du
pas de vague au sein de l'éducation
nationale et et les moyens qui
permettraient de soutenir tant les
enseignants que les équipes
administratives face à la à la remise de
en cause de leur autorité avant de
donner la parole au au président buffet
s'il le souhaite je dois vous rappeler
monsieur le ministre que nos commissions
s'étant doté des pouvoirs de commission
d'enquête un faux témoignage à
l'occasion de cette audition serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 14 et 15 du code
pénal et je vais vous inviter donc à à
prêter serement dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le
jure merci Monsieur président de la
commission des lois ou monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre moi j'ai
deux observations à faire en complément
de celle qui VI d'être faite par par le
président Lafond vu du côté commission
des lois ce qui on s'intéresse à ce
qu'il a dit naturellement euh on ne
s'interdit rien à la commission des lois
mais tout de même on a besoin de de de
savoir un peu ce que vous pensez sur la
protection fonctionnelle et sa mise en
œuvre ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose qui nous importe c'était
un peu de vous avez initié la protection
physique pour le coup les établissements
scolaires euh comment ces ch ceci a été
engagé est-ce que ça va suffisamment
vite enfin bon tout ce qui tourne autour
de de cet aspect-l c'est vrai que on ne
peut pas évoquer l'affaire en
particulier il une procédure judiciaire
ça nous serions mis en difficulté de le
faire on vous mettra en difficulté on se
mettrait nous-même en difficulté mais
tout ce qui s'est passé postérieurement
de à cette ce dramatique crime faut
l'appeler comme par son nom qu'elle a
été finalement le rôle du ministre enfin
du ministère pas du ministre par mais du
ministre pour essayer de répondre à
cette situation voilà merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsur je vais vous
laisser la la parole pour un propos
liminire et puis après vous connaissez
le principe de nos audition
chacun des chacune des sénatrices et
chacun des sénatrices des sénateurs qui
le souhait bien sûr vous vous
interrogeront merci beaucoup messieurs
les les présidents Mesdames et Messieurs
les les sénateurs et sénatrices je suis
bien sûr heureux de répondre à votre
invitation et de pouvoir contribuer à
éclairer ce sujet qui est essentiel non
seulement l'affaire pati elle-même mais
mais tout ce qui l'environne et et qui
permet de de comprendre à la fois les
enjeux les grands défis puisque ces
défis sont énormes et puis peut-être les
améliorations toujours toujours
possibles euh je pense c'est important
de pour reciter les choses dans la ligée
des questions que vous venez de poser de
parler de ce qui est antérieur à
l'assassinat de Samuel pati ce qui est
postérieur la deuxième ne peut se
comprendre qu'avec la première et
évidemment j'aurais à cœur quand même de
vous dire que beaucoup de choses se sont
faites dès 2017 201 vous avez d'ailleurs
commencé à le dire en évquant le commiss
des sages la cité puis en m'efforçant
quand même de distinguer toujours ce qui
relève du droit et ce qui relève de la
culture ce que ce qui relève de
l'éducation nationale et ce qui n'en
relève pas et bien tout bien sûr tout
ceci interagit tout ceci est complexe et
c'est on doit à la fois démêler ses fil
et bien montrer leur leur connexion
c'est ça le l'enjeu si on veut être
équanime dans le diagnostic que l'on
fait alors s'agissant de enfin si je
parle maintenant d'un point de vue un
peu chronologique
euh dès 2017 à peine avais-je pris mes
fonctions que parmi les premières choses
que j'ai pu dire il y avait d'abord
l'inquiétude par rapport aux atteintes à
la
laïcité la vigilance par rapport au
phénomène pas de vague et en 3ème lieu
la création de dispositifs pour faire
face à
cela il y a à la fois des des Oros et
des écrits sur ce sur ce point auquel
vous pouvez évidemment vous vous
référer la dès le dès mes premiers
discours au recteur aux inspecteurs
d'académie notamment en Sorbonne dès le
mois de juin je dis j'utilise cette
formule que j'utiliserai 100 fois le pas
de VAC c'est
fini on arrête la culture du de la
volonté de ne pas signaler pour ne pas
inquiéter et évidemment il suffit pas de
le dire pour que ça s'arrête du du jour
au lendemain chacun chacun le comprend
mais d'emblé par exemple une des
premières chose que j'ai dit dès juin
2017 c'était que les chefs
d'établissement en aucun cas n'était
évalué sur le nombre signalement qui
était fait que autrement dit soit le
établissement est relativement pacifique
et tant mieux s'il y a peu de
signalement soit il ne l'est pas et s'il
y a beaucoup de signalement ben c'est un
signe de qualité aussi du chef
d'établissement ce qui ne va pas c'est
quand il y a peu de signalement alors
que l'établissement ne va pas cette
cette règle là était clairement établie
et a eu une série d'impact en chaîne
bien entendu pas à 100 % pas
parfaitement mais la la tendance était
clairement imprimée la deuxième chose
que que j'ai pu faire au-delà de cette
tonalité mais j'insiste sur la tonalité
parce que sur l'ensemble des choses que
nous allons voir la tonalité est
fondamentale c'est-à-dire que l'autorité
politique commencé par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale doit en permanence
mettre le système dans une forme de de
pression sur cette question pour que
tout le monde comprenne que 1 c'est une
priorité et que de chaque acteur qui
jouera le jeu sera protégé pour le faire
suivi pour le faire ce que je me suis
toujours efforcé de faire dans toutes
les circonstances c'est-à-dire une
culture de la vérité en en réalité pour
aller vers une culture de l'efficacité
c'était vraiment cela l'enjeu la
deuxième chose qui a été faite à ce
moment-là ça a été la création au
ministère à la fois d'un lieu physique
et d'une institution c'est-à-dire une
cellule de crise à quelques mètres de de
mon bureau qui était faite non seulement
pour les crises donc en cas de crise de
quelque nature que ce soit par exemple
les catastrophes naturelles ou les
crises de de l'ordre public
avec le genre de dispositif qu'il y a
dans ces cas-là téléphonique télévisuel
enfin tout l'ensemble des moyens de
communication qui permettent de
coordonner l'action des acteurs de de
l'État et puis de coordonner l'action
entre l'éducation nationale et la police
j'ai fait dans le même
temps le tout un travail de coordination
avec le ministère de l'Intérieur là
aussi c'est je pense intéressant
d'entendre le ministère de l'Intérieur
sur cette question puisque je crois
pouvoir dire que c'est ouvert une aire
de de coopération entre la poli la
police et l'éducation nationale sans
nuage euh parce que très clairement euh
mon message était euh les deux les deux
institutions doivent se parler elles
visent exactement les mêmes buts il n'y
a aucune frontière euh autre que de
compétence évidemment à mettre entre les
deux ce qui s'est traduit par le fait
que j'ai nommé un préfet euh à la à la
tête de la cellule que j'ai créé euh qui
a été une une cellule euh pour
l'ensemble des enjeux de sécurité qui a
représenter une assez grande différence
avec ce qui existait précédemment
puisque avant précédemment on avait un
dispositif qui s'appelait fait
établissement avec quatre niveaux de
signalement euh du moins grave au plus
grave le niveau 4 étant le niveau le le
plus grave et ce système avait
évidemment le mérite d'exister était
permettait d'avoir de manière un peu
empirique la remontée des fait mais ce
n'était pas un système qui permettait de
de mettre un un accent tonique sur sur
lesffets les plus graves en réalité il y
avait une forme
de de fonctionnement sans distinction
des des choses et puis un peu empirique
au sens où ça relevait un peu de ce que
chaque cabinet de chaque recteur pouvait
filtrer en en la matière euh nous avons
demandé que l'effet de niveau 4 soit
l'objet d'une saisie immédiate et
directe de cette de cette cellule et que
cela puisse faire l'objet d'un
traitement entre le National et et
l'académique ce qui d'ailleurs sera ce
qui se passera dans le cas de de
l'affaire pati c'estàdire que ça sera en
en amont de l'assassinat un fait un fait
signalé cette cette cellule a donc
représenté une une nouveauté très
importante et elle a fait l'objet d'une
circulaire de ma part à la fin du mois
d'août
2017 et tout ceci semble comment
dirais-je naturel à postériori je tiens
à dire que ça ne l'était pas c'est
c'est-à-dire que déjà ont pointé des
critiques sur mon esprit
sécuritaire le
côté peut-être la priorité excessive que
j'accordais à ces à ces questions et et
pourtant cet outil a été utile et comme
toujours évidemment on ne voit pas tout
ce qui est évité grâce aux dispositifs
qui sont mis en place mais ce dispositif
a notamment permis une coopération très
étroite encore une fois il y avait un
préfet à sa tête donc la coopération
police éducation nationale dont j'ai
souhaité qu'elle se retrouve en en
miroir à l'échelle académique à
l'échelle de chaque établissement c'est
s déroulé à plusieurs reprises je me
suis rendu au ministère de l'Intérieur
pour parler devant les préfets euh à
l'invitation des ministres de
l'Intérieur successifs euh de façon à à
bien euh cadrer cet élément cette
question qui portait sur les sujets
disons de de violence en général de
c'est précisé aussi sur un des
sous-ensembles qui était la question des
atteintes à la laïcité et des atteintes
au aux valeurs de la République euh sur
ce point euh j'ai en parallèle fait donc
d'autres choses qui ont qui sont venu
compléter vous l'avez mentionné tout à
l'heure la création du Conseil des Sages
de de la laïcité euh cette création a
représenté quelque chose je crois
d'assez important puisque d'abord elle a
envoyé un signal bien sûr sur
l'importance de ce sujet il y avait
d'ailleurs une smétrie que j'établissais
entre euh le fait de rescientificiser
l'éducation nationale c'est-à-dire
d'avoir des politiques public éducative
inspiré par les enjeux scientifiques
c'est la création du Conseil
scientifique de l'éducation nationale et
la rerépublicanisation de l'éducation
nationale et ça c'est la création du
Conseil des Sages de de la laïcité ce
conseil des sages a a eu avait un
premier mérite c'était d'envoyer ce
signal il avait un mérite un deuxième
mérite non moins important qui était la
création de normes de référence pour
l'éducation nationale sachant que
malheureusement pour les sujets de
laïcité on rentre souvent dans de très
grandes
casuistique l'affaire de la la Baya a
d'ailleurs montré ultérieurement je
tiens je profite de l'occasion
pardonnez-moi de le dire pour dire que
les signaux tentatoires étaient interdit
quand j'étais ministre et que le la Baya
en faisait partie je ferme cette
parenthèse mais vous vous comprendrez
que j'ai à cœur de le préciser le
cette le Conseil des Sages donc a a
travaillé sur cette question en en
établissant un vadmcom de la de la
laïité ce vadmcom a donc été une
référence et surtout il a été sans arrêt
en en évolution pour tenir compte des
problèmes et puisque vous avez reçu le
Conseil des Sages vous vous connaissez
le mode de fonctionnement cela a permis
tout un travail aussi de conception
d'une stratégie vis-à-vis des des
questions de de
laïcité en même temps que tout ceci nous
avons créé des équipes valeur de la
République à l'échelle de chaque
académie ces équipes était faite pour
être
opérationnel sur le terrain j'avais à
l'esprit un
dispositif que j'avais expérimenté et
initié comme recteur de créteille en
2009 2008 pardon qui était celui des
équipes mobiles de sécurité qui existe
toujours aujourd'hui et qui maintenant
est national et qui ob toujours à la
même logique en réalité c'est-à-dire
avoir des équipes capables d'intervenir
sur le terrain
euh physiquement à la appel des
établissements comme souvent c'est un
dispositif qui avait été assez contesté
à sa création et qui est aujourd'hui
devenu très demandé sur sur le terrain
parce qu'il apporte une certaine
sécurité les équipes laïcité étaient
donc faites pour cela et elles ont
rempli ce rôle c'est-à-dire que elles
doivent faire en sorte que justement il
y ait pas de pas de vague et qu'il n'y
ait pas de sentiment de solitude
lorsquil y a un problème de lacité pour
que le les personnes
interviennent quand quand le problème se
se pose
cette ce
système permettait aussi d'avoir un une
idée enfin une évaluation permanente de
la situation c'est autour de les deux
systèmes combinés celui de du qu'on
appelle le cmva donc le le le le système
de remontée que j'ai décrit en premier
et le système de d'existence d'un
conseil des sages de la lcité ces deux
institutions ensemble travaillant
étroitement permettaient de faire une
photographie régulière et et je m'étais
engagé et je je l'ai fait tous les
trimestres de donner le nombre de
signalements qui a toujours tourné
autour de 600 signalements trimestriel
de des atteintes à la lécité sauf
évidemment pendant la la période la
période
covid qui a évidemment troublé un
certain nombre de choses le c'est donc
tout ce dispositif qui a représenté une
une
nouveauté d'abord en envoyant un signal
je dirais philosophique politique
administratif qui était qu'on regardait
en face les sujets d'atteinte à la
laïcité et qui ensuite embrayait vers
une capacité opérationnelle
cette ce système s'est donc déployé tout
au long des années 2018 2019 et 2020
c'est le système qui était en
fonctionnement quand il y a
eu l'assassina de de Samuel paatti alors
comme vous l'avez dit je rentrerai pas
dans les détails qui seront pour le le
moment judiciaire de de de l'affaire de
l'affaire pati mais je peux simplement
rappeler que lorsque
le semaine fatidique précédent
l'assassinat a a eu lieu euh à chacune
des étapes cette équipe était é a été
mobilisé c'est donc les points que je
viens de vous dire euh ont été mis en
marche euh et c'est et la principale du
collège a avait été imprégné de ces de
ces règles du jeu c'est ce qui fait
qu'elle a euh accompagné Samuel pati
pour le dépôt de la plainte c'est ce qui
fait qu'il y a eu toute une série
d'interventions des inspecteurs je je
suis prêt évidemment à répondre pas
forcément aujourd'hui mais quand on
voudra sur ces pointslà mais d'autres
que moi le savent mieux que moi beaucoup
de choses ont été écrites dans des
rapports d'inspection et autres mais je
voudrais qu'on regarde ce point qui est
que dans la chaîne de causalité qui a la
fin débouche sur ce drame euh ce
dispositif a existé alors évidemment
l'idée qui vient imiatement l'esprit
c'est ben c'était donc insuffisant
puisque l'assassinat a eu mais c'est là
que je voudrais redire aussi que le le
la question de la connextion éducation
nationale police et la question disons
de la société qui environne l'éducation
nationale est évidemment à regarder de
très près dans ces dans dans ces anjeux
là c'est-à-dire qu'il y a ce que l'on
pouvait prévoir et ce que l'on ce que
l'on n'a pas su prévoir évidemment le
chacun voudrait rétrospectivement avoir
empêché ce C cet assassinat mais les les
les les les mécanismes qui étaient à
notre portée avait avaient été conçus
alors ça renvoie évidemment à une autre
question qui est celle que vous avez
posé qui est qu'avons-nous fait après
com qu'avons-nous fait pour renforcer
renforcer cela il y a eu d'abord je
dirais des des des sujets que je
qualifierais presque de de culturel
c'est-à-dire que ça a représenté une un
tel choc pour tout le monde pour toute
la France et pour l'éducation nationale
en particulier que il y a eu un cran
supplémentaire je dirais dans la culture
du signalement chacun a compris que
c'était important de d'aller d'aller
plus loin en la matière il y a eu aussi
à ce moment-là euh le sentiment qu'il
était absolument nécessaire d'aller
beaucoup plus loin dans laformation
complète et totale de l'ensemble des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale ce
qui tout de suite nous renvoie aux
enjeux d'échelle de l'éducation
nationale c'est-à-dire que faut toujours
le rappeler même si vous le savez bien
euh que on parle de plus d'un million de
de fonctionnaires de plus de 12 millions
d'élèves euh et que évidemment il y a
pas toujours une homogénéité de de
toutes les compétences de tous les
réflexes de de l'ensemble des enjeux de
culture professionnelle dans tous les
domaines et que cette ce c'est
évidemment ce gigantisme suppose ensuite
des formes de d'effet matriciel disons
que l'on doit rechercher dans dans dans
l'action qui est dans l'action qui est
menée concrètement euh ce qui a été fait
sous la responsabilité de l'inspecteur
général horaire honoraire
auain ça a été la création d'un système
de de formation qu'on a appela le
système des mes puisque de manière très
approfondie nous avons formé 1000
personnes qui à leur tour sont devenus
les formateurs de formateurs à l'échelle
du pays selon un système qui s'est
déployé qui dont je peux pas rendre
compte aujourd'hui nétant plus en
fonction mais c'est déjà des centaines
de milliers de gens qui sont qui ont été
concernés par par cette formation que ce
soit les cadres ou l'ensemble des des
professeurs et et personnel
administratif de de la maison éducation
nationale nous avons doublé cela de de
là aussi d'autres effets matricielle en
matière de de formation je pense
notamment au diplôme qui a été créé avec
l'aide du knam et à la Sorbonne par
Pierre Henri tavoyot et qui lui aussi
contribue à cette formation des des des
cadres de façon à ce que là aussi ce
sujet-l soit euh traduise la plus grande
homogénéité possible euh vous avez fait
référence à
l'hétérogénéité tout à l'heure et
évidemment vous avez vous avez raison je
ne prétends pas que nous sommes arrivés
à cette homogénéité de culture et de et
de réflexe mais mais la première chose
que je disais et que je redis là c'est
que cette homogénéité est indispensable
il y a beaucoup de sujets sur lequels il
faut pas rechercher l'homogénéité on a
besoin au contraire de que d'avoir de
grandes différences
d'avoir mil fleurs qui fleurissent sur
sur plein d'aspects mais pas sur le
sujet de la laïcité qui ne peut pas
s'accompagner d'une forme de
d'hétérogénéité de de de de différence
local qui serait accepté et cetera c'est
typiquement un sujet qui réclame de la
centralité de de l'homogénéité et c'est
ce que nous avons recherché non
seulement par tout ce que j'ai dit sur
le Conseil des Sages de la laïcité et la
création des normes mais aussi par le
système de formation et et
alors je suis peut-être un peu long mais
je j'essaie de de répondre à à tout ce
que vous avez dit en introduction ça
nous ça nous renvoit donc à
l'hétérogénéité concrète existante sur
le terrain et vous avez fait référence
un peu à à une forme de de problème
peut-être générationnel queon peut
constater sur ce sujet ou sur d'autres
c'est-à-dire vision différente de qu'on
pourrait trouver peut-être chez les
moins de 35
ans en matière de d'interprétation de ce
qu'il faut mettre derrière les valeurs
de de la République c'est un sujet
auquel je suis très sensible et qui qui
est un sujet global systémique euh et
qui n'est pas que sur la question des
valeurs de la République et c'est pour
ça aussi que sur ce sujet sur lequel
j'ai été très critiqué
j'ai été je crois
euh le plus en amont possible de ce qui
existe en la matière c'est pour ça que
j'ai dénoncé certaines choses qui
peuvent se passer parfois à l'université
qui enchaînent ont un impact ensuite sur
nos futurs professeurs et qui ensuite
crée une une vision des choses qui en
tout cas ne correspond pas à la norme de
ce qu'est l'éducation nationale
l'éducation nationale se ni dès qu'elle
s'éloigne des principes républicains qui
qui ont été fondateur pour elle et ces
principes n'ont pas vocation à varier
considérablement dans le temps peuvent
évidemment tenir compte de la société
telle qu'elle évolue mais ce sont
toujours les mêmes depuis les années
1880 et la fondation de l'École de la
République euh et donc la laïcité n'a
pas changé de sens depuis lors elle doit
évidemment tenir compte de la société
telle qu'elle est mais elle n'a pas
changé de sens et euh
c'est des façons de penser complètement
différentes de cette tradition
républicaine qui ont c'est vrai innerver
notre
notre débat public je dirais et euh et
évidemment euh on ne peut pas laisser se
développer euh c'est pourquoi je suis
pas fataliste sur cette question je
pense que les enjeux de formation
auxquels j'ai fait référence sont
fondamentaux par- de là les enjeux
disons procédures
les enjeux disons juridiques et
administratifs sur lesquels je je
reviendrai sans doute mais mais en
réalité il y a pour parler en terme
presque marxiste non seulement les
superstructures mais les infrastructures
autrement dit nous devons être très
attentif à la culture publique qui
existe dans notre société sur sur sur
ces questions et c'est celle-là qui
permet d'avoir les réflexes civiques et
qui permet aussi que tous les acteurs
aillent dans le même sens et s'il n'y a
pas ça on pourra faire les meilleur lois
du monde les meilleures procédures du
monde si si on n pas agi sur ces aspects
culturels on ne pourra pas avoir des
résultats complètement satisfaisants
d'où l'importance d'avoir des des
réflexions sur ces questions et de faire
que à l'éducation nationale déjà sans
parler des autres champs si on est
fonctionnaire de l'éducation nationale
c'est qu'on adhère par définition à ces
enjeux et ensuite si on est élèv et
parents d'élèves c'est qu'on est aussi
forcément
dans le respect de de ces questions
j'avais utilisé des termes assez forts
pour le dire lors de la formation des
m000es ces termes mont été reprochés à
l'époque mais je pour dire que si on
n'est pas si je dois les redire c'était
que je disais si on n'est pas d'accord
avec ça personne n'est obligé de
travailler à l'éducation nationale le
cette je je crois profondément à ça et
que voilà être fonctionnaire de
l'éducation nationale c'est avoir des
droits et des devoirs et ceci fait
partie des des devoirs de manière
absolument incontestable à mon avis
voilà
c'était c'est c'est c'est c'est ce
renforcement là qui a eu lieu et du côté
des procédures évidemment un
travail d'accentuation du lien de
l'éducation nationale avec la police
dont une des dimensions a été
euh le fait de rechercher une plus
grande des réflexes plus rapides et une
plus grande sévérité lorsque il y avait
des menaces ou des oui ou des des
attaques vis-à-vis de professeurs
euh et cette c'est ce qui a conduit dans
dans l'Académie de versaill qui a été
beaucoup montré du doigt c'est sur ces
sujets mais je voudrais quand même
mettre tout ça en perspective c'est ce
qui a conduit à ce qu'on pour appeler
une protection renforcée des professeurs
à la suite de la de la fairepie euh ce
qui s'est traduit par exemple là aussi
il y a toutes les choses qu'on ne voit
pas on voit évidemment les drames mais
on ne voit pas ce qui est empêché un
certain nombre de de parents d'élèves
menaçants comparable aux parents
d'élèves à l'origine de la de
l'affirepathie ont fait l'objet de garde
à vue beaucoup plus rapide et
systématique que que ça n'était le cas
avant laaffirepathie parce qu'il y a eu
cette cette sévérité alors après il faut
faire preuve de discernement dans
l'exercice de cette euh de cette
réactivité mais euh mais c'est aussi euh
euh ces choses-là qui ont changé après
euh après
laffirepie voilà euh messieur les
président
titre d'introduction ce que je pouvais
dire
ouis merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
plusieurs collègues se sont inscrits
alors Monsieur Jacques
broperin merci cher Président je vrais
saluer monsieur le ministre d'éducation
nationale et et dire que c'est vrai
qu'on a tendance certains ont tendance à
oublier les choses très vite mais c'est
la vie politique qui est ainsi mais
d'autres ne les oublient pas et on sait
tout l'engagement que vous avez eu par
rapport à ça moi je vis voudrait revenir
euh pas pas jusqu'à Jean-Pierre Aubin
mais en 2015 on avait fait un rapport
sur faire revenir la République donc à
l'école on s'était déplacé au lycée avos
sur un lycée sous contrat donc de
confession musulmane et on avait visité
on était rentré par l'arrière de l'école
et on était rentré de manière moins
officielle que c'était prévu et puis à
l'écoute à la rencontre des élèves on
s'était rendu compte également que les
élèves ne pratiquit pas l'éducation
physique ensemble c'estàdire les les
garçons et les filles il y avait tout un
ensemble de choses qui nous avaient
choqué et pourtant lorsqu'on a rencontré
les inspecteur les IPR à ce moment-là il
n'avaient pas relevé cela donc déjà
depuis au bain mais après avec avec ce
ce rapport là et d'autres types de
report de rapport on on se rend compte
que dans l'éducation nationale pardon il
y a certaines structures qui ne qui ne
en tout cas vous parliez tout à l'heure
de de mettre le le fait de pas de vague
moi je m'interroge pour ne pas être trop
long je m'interroge quand même sur la
sur l'esprit et sur l'état d'esprit de
ce grand ministère là parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans un ministère
où on défend toujours un peu l'opprimée
on défend toujours on a eu on a aitionné
par l'intermédire des de président donc
la sœur de Samuel pati qui était en
colère mais elle était en colère par
rapport à cela il nous a dit qu'elle
avait été lâché par également son frère
avait été lâché par les enseignants
est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire dans ce grand ministère de
l'éducationnal pour qu'à un moment donné
on puisse aller plus loin je sais qu'il
y a peut-être ce syndrome de Vichy qui
nous tient en France qui fait que on
osse pas dire on n pas rentrer dans la
délation mais c'est pas de la délation
c'est du civisme qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait ajouter aux différents types de
dispositifs que vous avez mis en place
et on sait qu' ils ont été forts pour
essayer de changer cet cet état d'esprit
certains ont parlé à un moment donné de
police est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'un
moment donné qu'il y a un policier dans
chaque établissement scolaire est-ce
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait quelqu'un à
l'entrée de chaque ch établissement
scolaire qui puisse identifier chaque
personne qui rentre et qui sorte et on
sent que l'éducation nationale dans son
ensemble pas vous mais l'éducation
nationale é rétive par rapport à cela je
vous
remercie on va peut-être prendre toutes
les questions comme ça vous pourraz
répondre globalement Mariepierre
Meier merci monsieur le Président je
salue les deux présidents monsieur le
ministre et mes collègues alors vous
avez parlé d'un rapport et il y a eu en
effet un rapport de l'Inspection
Générale suite à la mort de Samuel pati
euh par contre les faits ont lieu eu
lieu le 20 octobre le rapport est paru
le en décembre donc pourquoi cette
temporalité extrêmement resserré et puis
j'aimerais savoir comment s'est opéré le
choix des personnes interrogées pour ce
rapport parce que lors de son audition
par notre commission d'enquête de Michel
paatti elle avait relevé à raison la
surprésentation des parents interrogés
quatre vis-à-vis des professeur 3 et
dans ce rapport il y a une grande part
d'autosatisfaction sur l'attitude de
l'Institut
et une mise en cause insistante de
Samuel Patti qui aurait été maladroit
dans sa manière d'enseigner la laïcité
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il est choquant
que ce soit ces points là qui soi
prioritairement retenus par le rapport
et ne faut pas ne faut-il pas s'alarmer
que son entretien avec sa hiérarchie est
principalement porté sur cela sur un ton
présenté dans le rapport comme
culpabilisant plutôt que de s'intéresser
à son état psychologique et aux menaces
dont il faisait l'objet je veux vous
alerter parce qu'il y a eu pas mal de
violences et que ce on se focalise
souvent sur les violences les plus
graves mais les violences verbales
formeraient la majorité des violences et
peuvent conduire à une dégradation
significative des conditions de travail
des enseignants concernés ce n'est pas
négligé la dimension répétée des
agissements de type de menace et insulte
constitutive d'un harcèlement moral
apparaît ainsi insuffisamment prise en
compte dans la réponse apporté par la
hiérarchie interne et extérieure à
l'établissement aux professeurs en
souffrance c'est ce qui ressort
notamment des témoignages de professeurs
que nous avons entendu récemment dans le
cadre de l'AD missission d'enquête qui
ont signalé avoir fait part de ces
insultes et menace leur hiérarchie qui
les a ignoré vous parlez de pas de vague
comme votre successeur mais nous on
entend de la part des professeurs que
c'est toujours de mise le pas de vague
dans notre rapport bilan des mesures
éducatives du quinquena mené avec mes
collègues max prisson anque billon nous
avions mis en lumière le sentiment des
enseignants de ne pas être soutenus par
l'institution en cas de remise en cause
de leur autorité ainsi que du une
moindre prise en compte de leurs plainte
par la police et la justice
comparativement à d'autres dépositaires
de l'autorité publique est-ce que c'est
un état de fait que vous avez constaté
quand vous étiez vous-même ministre et
enfin je vous alerterai sur la
protection
fonctionnelle parce que c'est un outil
mais qui vraiment se déploie
principalement sous la forme d'un
accompagnement de nature juridique et
que il faudrait aussi apporter des
solutions concrètes de
protection et à même de mettre
réellement sécurité les professeurs face
à des menaces
imminentes pour tirer les leçons de ce
qui s'est passé par rapport à la mort de
Samuel pati entre autres et en fait j'ai
eu récemment un cas qui a été porté à ma
connaissance d'un professeur
destinataire de menac et de mort à
l'encontre de sa personne et le rectorat
n'a pas pris en charge de façon adéquate
la sécurité de ce professeur ni évoquer
l'existence d'une procédure en place
pour faire face à de telles situations
dramatiques c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
votre sentiment là-dessus
suite Monsieur Henri Leroi
oui monsieur le ministre pardonnez-moi
de de de d'être très direct mais tout au
long de cette affaire vous étiez
ministre et vous la connaissez euh point
est utile de rappeler
l'ensemble de du déroulement monsieur
Patti a été entendu par la principale du
collège par les éducateurs et
manifestement il a témoigné de sa
crainte et de ses problèmes en terme de
sécurité il a même été jusqu'à le jour
précédent son attaque mettre un marteau
dans son sac pour se défendre et le
l'assassin est resté 20 minutes devant
le collège avant que les jeunes qui sont
aujourd'hui entre les mains de la
justice le désigne comme étant celui
qu'il fallait à
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas bien sûr pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez dit
que vous avez
été exposé devant les les préfets
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas été mis en
indisponibilité alors que véritablement
quand on se quand on lit le déroulé de
l'affaire on se rend compte que ce
monsieur appelé au secours et avait
besoin de protection la famille est
vraiment catastrophé et notamment Michal
pati qui a témoigné qu'on a eu
l'occasion d'en discuter
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas été protégé par
l'Éducation nationale et a été
pratiquement monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi mais ce sont les propos qui
ont été abandonné totalement à lui-même
voilà tout simplement merci merci
Monsieur Martin
levrier merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
propos liminires et votre rappel de de
la volonté que vous aviez de casser le
le pas de vague et c'est ma première
question finalement on parle du pas de
vague comme un fait mais d'où vient le
pas de vague et quel est-il exactement
pourquoi est-il arrivé dans le système
scolaire à ce point-là est-il devenu
quasiment une philosophie du système
pendant près de 20 ans d'où vient-il et
comment peut-on le casser a-t-on réussi
à le casser aujourd'hui j'en suis pas
certain ma deuxième question concerne
aussi les chefs d'établissement et et
proviseur des des lycées quelle est leur
responsabilité leur rôle exact pour
participer à à à l'éducation à la licité
comment peuvent-ils travailler ou agir
avec les parents travailler ou agir avec
leur personnel avec le personnel
enseignant quelles sont leur respalités
et se sentent-ils finalement
suffisamment soutenu par une hiérarchie
qui donne le sentiment d'être
profondément vertical et qui donne
parfois le sentiment de déresponsabil
déresponsabiliser les personnes pardon à
cause de cette verticalité et puis la
dernière question qui concerne peut-être
plus l'affaire Samuel paatti qui était
dans mon département c'est c'est quelle
étaé le la position de la Fédération des
parents d'élèves par rapport à cet
événement comment ont-ils agi comment
ont-ils réagi surtout et derrière cette
question comment peut-on impliquer
beaucoup plus que ce soit dans les dans
les pardon au sein des établissements
public comme sous contrat d'association
les associations de parents d'élèves
pour agir sur agir de façon positive sur
la laïcité en lien avec les enseignants
bien sûr avec les avec les enfants et en
lien avec les chef d'établissements et
l'éducation nationale merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur monsieur Max
Brisson merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre
vous avez dit que le pas de vague
n'existait plus depuis votre passage au
sendis rue de Renel et je veux saluer
votre engagement sur le sujet il était
réel pour essayer de faire reculer cette
cangraine mais pensez-vous pour autant
et cela a été dit par d'autres
intervenants avant moi à commencer par
Martin levrier pensez-vous que toute la
hiérarchie a été guérie de ce mal
surtout lorsque les professeurs c'était
bien le cas de Samuel paatti ne
transigeent par rapport au professeurs
qui comme Samuel Patti ne transige pas
sur l'enseignement des principes de la
République et du principe de laïcité
inscrit dans notre
Constitution je rejoins ainsi un peu ce
qui a été dit et par Martin livvrier et
par Jacques groperin et et par Marie
Pierre Monier à savoir ir qu'il est
peut-être encore qu'il est toujours plus
aisé pour un professeur de
s'autocensurer s'il veut finalement
avoir le soutien de sa hiérarchie plutôt
que d'appliquer les programmes dans leur
intégralité et compris ce qui peut
déplaire à certains dans la mise en
œuvre de ces programmes deuxièmement
vous avez longuement parlé dans votre
propos introductif du conseil de la
laïcité que pensez-vous des
transformations du périmètre et de la
composition du conseil de la laïcité
décidé par votre successeur le
pensez-vous toujours en capacité de
jouer le rôle que vous lui avez indiqué
signifié et que vous nous avez rappelé
enfin ma trème question portera sur la
formation des professeurs armer les
professeurs pour renseigner le principe
de laïcité et l'ensemble des programmes
nécessite une formation claire et
cohérente
pensez-vous que tel qu'elle est
aujourd'hui dispensée sous l'gide de
l'université les professeurs sont bien
armés pour enseigner le principe de
laïcité et l'ensemble des programmes
lorsqu'il touche au principe de la
République ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
serait temps de s'interr projet que
l'éducation nationale reprenne la main
sur toutes parties de la formation des
professeurs merci
Monsieur Madame dearco
pardon ah voilà
oui monsieur le ministre je reviens sur
l'audition de Michel paatti où elle a
critiqué très vivement donc
la conduite de l'enquête de l'inspection
générale de
l'éducation sur l'ASS l'attentat sur son
frère donc seuls trois professeurs on
été attendu entendu sur 51 et le rapport
selon elle aurait été bouclé en 15 jours
lors de l'audition elle a dit que
certains enseignants n'auraient pas
souhaité témoigner par peur non pas de
menace terroriste mais par crainte ne
pas avoir par exemple leur mutation ou
une notation donc moi je trouve sa
remarque très inquiétante que pouvez
nous dire sur la façon dont a été mené
ce
rapport merci Madame et Monsieur
laelec Merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le
Ministre merci d'avoir recontextualiser
les choses et d'emblé je voudrais dire
ici que je n'ai pas le moindre doute
quant à l'ampleur de votre engagement et
quant à l'authenticité de
celui-ci pour au fond aborder un sujet
extrêmement
complexe la République ses valeurs celle
de la
laïcité avec
évidemment des procédures attentatoires
qui peuvent être insidieus et au cas
particulier très violent je n'y reviens
pas alors vous nous dites depuis 1880
effectivement les principes restent
fondamentalement les mêmes c'est c'est
vrai et en même temps je nuancerai le
propos en ce sens que je me permets de
vous dire que personnellement je dois à
l'école de la République et à l'école
laïque d'avoir fait de moi ce que
modestement je suis j'ai donc de bonnes
raisons de lui
être très reconnaissant ça n'est
peut-être pas le cas de tout le monde
donc je crois qu'il faut le comprendre
en tout cas c'est un élément de
fragilisation alors évidemment l'école
ne peut pas tout mais l'école peut
beaucoup
elle peut beaucoup et elle est
dépositaire en même temps de ce qui
traverse notre société les phénomènes de
violence je je ne m'étends pas donc il
est normal qu'on lui demande beaucoup et
au regard du phénomène de violence il y
a une question que je me pose quand
même aussi c'est celle de la protection
fonctionnelle
et je me
demande si cette protection
fonctionnelle ne devrait pas être de
droit pour les
enseignants si elle était de droit pour
les enseignants ça n'interdirait pas les
recours les risques d'abus et cetera
mais si la protection fonctionnelle
était de droit je pense que nous
pourrions éviter les lourds
inconvénients dont on a beaucoup parlé
ici et ailleurs et je pense également
que ça serait la bonne méthode pour
regagner la confiance du monde
enseignant je pense qu'on a besoin
d'eux et je pense que ceci ne
fragiliserait pas les procédures mieux
vaut prévenir que guérir et la
protection fonctionnelle d'emblé et de
droit serait une bonne chose je le dis
d'autant plus que en tant que
parlementaire il nous est compliqué
d'amender tout texte dans ce sens
puisqu'on nous opposerait l'article 40
donc je pense qu'il serait la
responsabilité du gouvernement
d'envisager cette procédure qui
accorderait donc la protection
fonctionnelle de droit à l'ensemble des
asseignants un des éléments de la
réponse évidemment merci de votre
attention
billon merci Monsieur mieur les présid
président merci monsieur le ministre
pour les les propos liminires que vous
avez eu j'aurais une question assez
simple puisque vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que il était important qu'à
partir du moment où les fonctionnaires
de l'éducation nationale adhèrent aux
valeurs républicaines adur adhèrent
pardon à aux valeurs de laïcité euh et
donc ils adhèrent ils ont des droits et
des devoirs à partir du moment où ils
sont fonctionnaires de l'éducation
nationale donc cette demande me paraît
bien entendu légitime mais à quel moment
va-t-on finalement partager cette
obligation avec ces fonctionnaires de
l'éducation nationale à quel moment
pourrait-il en avoir connaissance
comment cela va-t-il se mettre en œuvre
et finalement cette cette demande
d'adhésion qui est tout à fait légitime
je le
répète est-elle à partagée avec tous les
fonctionnaires parce que finalement
pourquoi on demanderait uniquement aux
fonctionnaires de l'éducation ation
nationale donc la laïcité ma deuxième
question ce serait aussi sur la la
laïcité et la mise à mal de la laïcité
ces dernières années à la fois dans
l'espace public et dans l'école de la
République alors comment envisagez-vous
des programmes qui permettrai de
redresser la barre si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi et ne pensez-vous pas que la
laïcité a souffert aussi de
tergiversation de renoncement depuis un
certain nombre d'années de positions
assez ambigu sur un certain nombre de
sujets qui font que même les enseignants
même les fonctionnaires quels qu'ils
soient même les parents même les élèves
se demandent c'est quoi la laïcité je
vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je crois qu'il y a plus de
question je vais en rajouter une ah
Madame G Madame G monsieur les
présidents bonsoir Monsieur le
Ministre bonsoir heureuse de de vous
entendre sur un sujet sur lequel comme
mes collègues je doute pas du tout de
votre engagement euh je je partage la
question sur le caractère automatique de
la protection fonctionnelle qui peut
libérer aussi parfois la hiérarchie de
doutes de peur et cetera et que sur le
sujet de la laïcité est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui une interprétation
totalement disruptive si je puis dire ou
nous tous ici qui avait une une
conception de la laïcité qui a
protection des libertés individuelles et
qui est la règle qui nous permet de
vivre ensemble est-ce que cette
conception n'est pas aujourd'hui
totalement entre guillemets dépassée
dans l'esprit d'une jeunesse qui parfois
conçoit la laïcité comme une entrave à
la liberté individuelle et que donc les
règles que l'on peut mettre aujourd'hui
dans notre conception et enfin ces
règles elles sont parfois mal comprises
parce que on ne parle plus plus le même
langage je vous
remercie dernière question que je vais
poser dans l'application du principe de
de la laïicité est-ce que ne pensez pas
qu'il y a encore des flous dans ce fond
écho d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'enseignants dans la mise en œuvre
euh vous avez noté tout à l'heure la
différence d'appréciation de votre
successeur sur le port de la BAA se pose
aussi la question des sorties scolaires
ou l'application des règles des laïcité
fait débat est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas
intérêt à préciser au-delà du VAD Mcom
qui lui-même précise vous l'avez dit
mais est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas être
encore plus
précis dans le l'application de de de de
la léicité ce qui est autorisé ce qui ne
l'est
pas merci monsieur le ministre vous avez
la
parole on attirant votre attention que
sur certaines questions qui
concernent l'affaire Samuel Patti
vous invite à la
prudence merci monsieur le Président
pour les questions juridiques he pas
pour bien
sûr
sur donc je vais les prendre dans
l'ordre en commençant par le sénateur
grosérin et en remerciant tous ceux
d'entre vous qui ont commencé par bien
vouloir m'accorder une forme de de
continuité enfin de
d'esprit stable sur sur et et affirmé
sur le sujet de la
laïcité
le la question d'abord de l'état
d'esprit du du
ministère ça renvoie un peu à cette à ce
que j'ai dit en commençant sur la sur la
question disons culturelle et à
distinguer de la question juridique et
administrative et plusieurs des
questions qui ont été posées par les
sénateurs et sénatrices envoi à cette à
cet enjeu euh
et je voudrais dire quand en effet on
est dans un enjeu de de matrice
culturelle de dans notre pays et plus
généralement d'ailleurs dans les
sociétés dans les sociétés modernes nous
avons la chance d'avoir la matrice
républicaine je considère que c'est une
chance inoui euh que cette matrice
contrairement à ce que veulent nous
faire croire un certain nombre de
secteurs non seulement n'est pas désuett
ou même strictement française mais en
réalité correspond au défi de notre
temps c'estàd qu'on a besoin d'humanisme
on a besoin d'universalisme on a besoin
de considérer d'abord les êtres humains
comme ayant une égale dignité avant
d'entrer dans la question de leurs
appartenances diverses et variées euh et
on a besoin et je voudrais vraiment
insister sur ce point de ne plus avoir
le logiciel de la victimisation comme
étant le logiciel de lecture de la des
rapports en société et ce qui fait un
tort considérable et ça se voit dans le
détail de chaque affaire c'est que tout
le monde veut être toujours plus victime
que le voisin et que c'est dans cette
surenchère de la victimisation on a euh
finalement un un une course sans fin et
qui est un petit peu euh la clé de
compréhension de beaucoup de d'attitudes
le dans l'école de la 3e république le
le qui avait bien des défauts qui
étaient loin d'être parfaites mais il y
avait premièrement la foi dans le
progrès de dans le progrès en général et
dans le progrès par le système éducatif
en particulier et deuxièmement personne
cherchait à s'afficher comme victime de
quoi que ce soit euh là il y avait une
émulation euh qui était liée à la
méritocratie républicaine et qui était
favorable au plus faiblebl et donc les
plus faibles ne gagnent rien à la
logique de victimisation il gagnent au
contraire à la logique d'égalité tout
simplement et d'universalisme ce sont
des choses un peu simples que je suis en
train d'énoncer mais elles sont
fondamentales tant qu'on ne sort pas de
ça le combat est un combat un peu face
face à la vague pour le coup c'est pas
le pas de vague mais c'est face à la
vague c'est-à-dire une vague d' de de
d'interprétation du réel qui ne va pas
et euh quand vous vous voyez détail de
chaque affaire et compris l'affaire pati
vous voyez bien que la rhétorique de des
acteurs et notamment de certains élèves
c'est de de toujours se mettre sur ce
registre là et
cette tant que nous n'en sortirons pas
et donc pour en sortir il faut encore
une fois des matrices intellectuelles
c'est-à-dire c'est des enjeux de débat
public c'est des enjeux d'enseignement
c'est des enjeux de de paradigme qui
sont dans nos institutions et bien on
aura des des difficultés donc euh et
est-ce que notre système est exonéré de
de cela bien sûr que non comme
d'ailleurs aucun secteur de la de la
société et donc je reviens par rapport à
la question sur l'état d'esprit qui est
que notre il doit y avoir dans le cors
même de ce qui est enseigné à chaque
futur enseignant et de la formation
initiale et continue la logique
républicaine comme étant
consubstantiel à l'exercice du métier de
de professeur et bien entendu pour
répondre aussi à la question d'une
sénatrice ultérieurement ce raisonnement
vaut pour à mes yeux pour l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires c'est d'ailleurs une
sorte d'évidence hein c'est pas en train
de d'être très innovant en disant cela
normalement toute la jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État du 20e siècle nous a
appris qu'il y avait des droits et devir
du du fonctionnaire et que les valeurs
de la République en font en font partie
il faut simplement le le réaffirmer le
soleniser et en faire quelque chose de
d'assez central dans la vie générale il
faut je reviendrai sur d'autres aspects
par exemple pour répondre la à la
dernière question de la sénatrice Gatel
mais mais cette dimension culturelle est
est très très importante euh faut-il
avoir un un policier dans chaque
établissement scolaire euh je pense que
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut être
d'un très grand pragmatisme c'est-à-dire
que il faut évidemment pas avoir quelque
chose penser systématique là-dessus tel
collège rural n'en a absolument pas
besoin euh en milieu urbain dans
certaines circonstances il ne faut pas
s'interdire certains types d'interaction
j'ai en tête ce que nous avons fait à
Nice avec le maire de Nice qui a
mobilisé sa sa police municipale suite
au au traumatisme qui a représenté
l'attentat de de Nice pour avoir la
police municipale présente d'une manière
extrêmement pacifique et qui favorise la
la le dialogue entre notamment entre les
jeunes générations et et la police euh
dans les dans les écoles de la ville
c'est pour autant que je le sache une
réussite à à ce stade et et c'est
important d'inclure le les polices la
police municipale dans le raisonnement
que l'on peut avoir en la matière
puisqueen général s'il y a une police
municipale c'est qu'on est déjà en
milieu urbain un peu complexe et
donc et que ça permet aussi de mobiliser
cette catégorie des forces de l'ordre
euh la police nationale ne pe pas
toujours faire tout ce qu'il y a à faire
en la matière de façon générale on gagne
quelles que soient les mesures qui sont
prises sur le sujet à du dialogue euh
gendarmerie police justice aussi
d'ailleurs et et professeurs et élèves
d'où le fait qu'on a beaucoup
encouragé la présence de pour des pour
des dialogues pour des pour des cours de
d'éducation civique pour toutes sortes
de d'intervention de de de la police
ensuite euh sur les questions de la
madame la sénatrice Marie-Pierre Bier la
euh le porte sur le rapport alors comme
vous m'y invitez monsieur le Président
je vais pas être très euh euh trop
précis sur ces points euh je crois que
la la vraiment la réponse à faire c'est
confrontons le le et en plus je me si
vous voulez j'ai j'ai passé ma mes 5 ans
à à à prendre en compte les rapports de
l'inspection des inspections générales
qui par définition sont imparfaits par
définition peuvent toujours être être
critiqués mais qui en même représente un
un véritable travail de de
professionnels euh qui pour le coup euh
se sont engagés par par leur formation
et leur déontologie à rechercher
l'objectivité maximale
c'est ce rapport si on le si on a des
éléments de désaccord il faut tout
simplement le confronter à d'autres
éléments de l'enquête il est fait pour
cela et encore une fois sans rentrer
dans les détails je
voudrais insister chacun à la prudence
sur les interprétations qui sont faites
en la matière l'expression éducation
nationale ayant lâché le Samuel pati me
paraît une question un sujet qui doit
être regardé de très près quand on
regarde chacune des étapes encore une
fois je ne veux pas rentrer dans les
détails mais euh je vous demande
vraiment de de de regarder ça
avec objectivité sérénité euh et bien
sûr que je serai je suis le premier à
essayer de regarder ce qui a failli euh
dans chacune des étapes de la part de
l'éducation nationale mais aussi de la
part des des autres euh le de de tout de
toute personne euh je pense
que toutes les introspections doit
doivent être doivent être faites mais
que il faut essayer de rester euh euh le
plus le plus objectif possible euh sur
cette sur cette question le fait qu'il
était fait euh rapidement était
justement une exigence normale euh pour
euh égard à l'importance de ce qui
s'était passé pour avoir déjà à chaud
euh le recueil de de de tout ce que les
acteurs pouvaient dire et et bien
entendu ça peut se confronter à ce que
d'autres travaux dans la durée notamment
les travaux de la justice bien sûr
permettront de dire sur le déroulé des
des
événements on doit faire attention à des
interprétations parfois médiatiques ou
toutes sortes de de de choses qui
peuvent se passer dans dans la vie
publique
ou ùou c'est pas toujours
l'objectivation qui est qui est qui est
recherché ensuite sur la deuxème partie
de la question de la
de la sénatrice
Monier sur sur sur ce que vous avez pu
constater sur la le fait qu'il existe
encore des phénomènes de pas de vague je
je évidemment je n'en disconviens pas le
encore une fois étant donné le le
gigantisme du système et et voilà et la
grande l'ampleur de notre pays et de
notre système éducatif il y a évidemment
une situation qui reste très imparfaite
ce que j'affirme et répondant aussi un
peu par anticipation à ce qu'a dit le
sénateur Brisson c'est
que personne ne peut contester qu'on l'a
dit que P VAC s'arrêé il y avait donc
une parole institutionnelle sur ce sujet
il y a eu des mesures institutionnelles
et il y a eu un discours institutionnel
qui n'a pas varié d'un yota sur cette
question pendant les pendant les 5
années et et ce que j'affirme c'est que
ce discours et ces dispositifs ont eu
des conséquences concrètes et que l'on
pourrait avoir des témoignages de de
professeurs qui ont été entre guillemets
bénéficiaaires de cela mais j'affirme
avec vous madame la sénatrice que il y
avait que que évidemment ça n'a pas
débouché sur la fin totale du pas de
vague et que certains acteurs ont le pas
de vague intégré en eux-même en quelque
sorte et que et que c'est évidemment
cela qu'on doit qu'on doit éviter et et
que je moi je pense comme vous à chaque
enseignant et j'avais cela en tête avant
la firepathie et encore plus après la
firepathie le le sentiment de solitude
euh qu'un un enseignant peut éprouver
quand il a quand il subit des menaces ou
qu'il sent tout simplement que
l'autorité n'est pas respectée et que en
difficulté à cause de cela j'ai sans
arrêt eu en tête les la nécessité de
rechercher les moyens d'empêcher
d'empêcher et donc d'arriver à une à une
solidarité vis-à-vis de tout professeur
dans cette situation d'où la culture du
signalement d'où les dispositifs en la
matière je voudrais énoncer quelque
chose que chacun sait qui est que en la
matière c'est l'esprit d'équipe qui est
fondamental les établissements où ça va
bien c'est les établissements où il y a
une solidarité organique entre
l'ensemble des adultes de
l'établissement dès qu'il arrive des
faits de ce type et donc c'est aussi le
travail de l'éducation nationale que de
créer cet esprit d'équipe dans chaque
endroit et de venir en soutien de
l'équipe quand ce cet esprit d'équipe
n'est lui-même pas suffisant euh
j'indique au passage que parmi les
mesures qui ont un effet sur cela dans
la durée il y a ce que l'on a mis sur
pied à la suite de la loi de 2019 pour
l'école de la confiance sur l'évaluation
du système scolaire euh qui fonctionne
par euh donc corort successif
d'établissement depuis 2020 à peu près
environ enfin un peu moins de 20 % des
établissements entrent chaque année dans
cette auto-évaluation et dans les
éléments d'auto-évaluation puis
d'évaluation il y a les sujets de vie
scolaire et euh et donc de protection
des des des professeurs et des élèves de
climat Scola comme on dit et euh ça fait
partie des sujets structurels qui je
crois avancent bien euh permettre des
progrès euh mais bien sûr euh c'est
évidemment euh euh c'est c'est il y a
évidemment encore des des marges de
progrès je vous je vous l'accorde bien
volontiers et tant qu'il y aura un seul
professeur comme ceux que vous avez vu
euh qui vivent ce dont vous avez été ce
dont vous avez recueilli le témoignage
euh évidemment qu'on nous ne pouvons pas
être en en repos par rapport à ça et
qu'il faut euh faire plus et mieux dans
cette direction qui a été imprimée mais
ce que j'affirme c'est que une direction
a été imprimé
qu'il faut pas écraser les choses dans
le temps c'est-à-dire il faut se
remettre dans certains contextes et voir
à quel point aujourd'hui le le paradigme
de la laïcité je l'appelle ainsi pour
dire cela a
changé a été renforcé au cours des
dernières années parce que même quand
elle n'est pas respectée même quand il y
a des problèmes c'est quand même ça la
référence c'est-à-dire que c'est pas une
conception des des naturé de la laïcité
qui prévaut à l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui il y a des références qui
sont très claires et même si je
reconnais qu'il peut y avoir des
imperfections voire des des déviation
dans la mise en œuvre la référence est
clairire
euh je je relis cela la à la question
posée par le sénateur Alain CADC qui est
très complémentaire de de celle de la
sénatrice Monier sur la protection
fonctionnelle puisque vous l'avez posé
aussi madame la
sénatrice je suis assez en accord avec
ce que vous avez dit alors je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que la
protection fonctionnelle
est est assez systématique elle n'est
pas
automatique et donc passer de d'assez
systématique à automatique serait
probablement une une bonne évolution en
tout cas la question mérite d'être posée
et et le et et je pense que ça irait
dans la dans la bonne
direction sur ce qu'a dit le sénateur
Henri l j'ai un petit peu répondu par
anti iation
est difficile de d'en dire davantage là
mais
enfin vous pourriez interroger par
exemplef elle le sera dans le cadre
judiciaire mais la la principale du
collège de bois et je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire qu'elle a abandonné Samuel
Patti et elle était elle était
l'institution était l'élément le plus
proche de l'institution à ce momentl
mais évidemment je Seris amené me eximer
sur cela et mais j'invite vraiment à
regarder les faits tous les faits rien
que rien que les faits
sur la question les questions du
sénateur Martin librier le
le alors sur le la qui me demandait
d'abord d'où vient la culture du du pas
de vague je pense que c'est un état
d'esprit qui est d'ailleurs'est pas
l'apanage de l'éducation nationale qui a
plusieurs
source d'un degré de comment dir qu'on
peut condamner à des degrés divers euh
le degré le moins fort de condamnation
qu'on peut avoir c'est quand les gens
simplement cherchent à résoudre les
problèmes sorte de principe de
subsidiarité parfois mal compris mais en
tout cas qui qui est que ce qu'on peut
régler localement on n pas de raison
d'aller d'aller reporter plus haut et
c'est pas parfois c'est pas complètement
faux c'est-à-dire que bien sûr que sur
les petits sujets les petites questions
les petits problèmes le but n'est pas de
de de de d'encombrer le système en
quelque sorte par les par les petits
faits d'où la distinction dans dans le
système des faits de niveau 1 2 3 et et
4 donc ça c'est la moins mauvaise des
des raisons de l'existence du pas de
vague après il y a euh eu longtemps le
fait que sans doute
l'évaluation le système avait des
mécanismes d'évaluation qui
n'encourageaient pas les bons
comportements euh c'est pas le seul
domaine c'est pas le seul domaine dans
lequel euh la manière de concevoir
l'évaluation des
personnels un effet négatif sur les
comportements parce que en gros bah si
vous voulez avancer il vaut mieux
apparaître comme quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais rencontré de problème et toujours
à trouvver des situations lisses et
cetera donc c'est
évidemment une des causes je pense
qu'une forme d'infantilisation peut
aussi être une cause c'est-à-dire que
notre système trop euh trop pyramidale
aboutit parfois à ce à à cela et que là
on est sur une question culturelle qui
mérite d'être prise à bras le corp et
qui je crois l'a été encore une fois
tout ce qu'on a pu mettre en œuvre
contre la logique du pas de VAG nous
l'avons fait et du chemin du chemin
reste à faire
euh mais je crois que sur ce point comme
sur d'autres aussi il faut savoir
reconnaître les pas qui sont faits dans
la bonne direction j'ai à cœur de le
dire aujourd'hui euh sur d'autres sujets
ce serait d'actualité
euh sans se sans s'énerver si je peux
dire si on veut aller si on veut
vraiment progresser l'éducation
nationale c'est le long terme c'est les
sillons longs quand il y a des choses
qui sur 20 ans 30 ans ont dysfonctionné
on ne peut pas s'attendre à ce que en 3
ans 4 ans 5 ans tout s'améliore
parfaitement on peut faire des des
effets de discours là-dessus mais mais
la réalité c'est que on arrive dans la
par des effets de continuité c'est
d'ailleurs la
madame l'avant-dernière question je
crois l'avant avant-dernière pardon
madame la sénatrice pter là-dessus sur
la question de de l'absence de zigzag
c'est qu'il faut de la continuité c'est
vrai en matière pédagogique c'est vrai
en matière éducative en matière de de de
de sécurité et
donc et donc encore une fois sur
l'ensemble des choses dont je vous parle
aujourd'hui je ne prétends en aucun cas
que la situation aurait atteint un
certain degré de perfection en revanche
je prétends qu'une bonne direction a été
imprimée et que il faut approfondir et
euh et aller jusqu'au bout de de de cela
euh sur euh comment les professeurs
peuvent-ils agir sur la la laïcité euh
c'est une c'est alors il y ça rejoint
aussi d'autres questions qui ont été
posées j réponds par avance
euh par exemple celle de la sénatrice
Gatel mais c'est euh le fait que on doit
tenir compte des phénomènes que nous
constatons disons de problèmes
intergénérationnels en la matière et
donc il s'agit pas seulement d'assiner
des principes il faut aussi les
illustrer les faire vivre et comprendre
aussi les les problématiques auquel ça
envoie les jeunes sont par exemple à
juste titre très sensibles à la question
de la discrimination il faut bien faire
comprendre par des cas concrets et par
des explicitation que la la laïcité et
la meilleure et et les valeurs de la
République sont les meilleurs
contre la contre la discrimination il
faut raisonner par par objectif il faut
aussi faire vivre les valeurs de la
République par des
actes les cours d'éducation civique sont
absolument nécessaires mais pas
suffisants d'où l'important de faire
vivre le civisme dans les établissements
scolaires c'est un facteur d'union c'est
un facteur de
d'illustration d'où l'importance
d'initiatives multiples qui ont pu être
prise pour que les élèves soient engagés
dans de
l'action civique bien sûr le le service
national universel fait partie de ces de
ces sujets ça n'est pas le ça n'est pas
le
seul
le sur les parents d'élèves alors
appliqué à laaffire patie là aussi je
renvoie au aux questions judiciaire mais
ça fait partie de de le du regard large
qu'il faut et objectivé qu'il faut
avoir sur comment l'ensemble des acteurs
ont réagit à ce à ce moment-là euh je me
contenterai de dire que dans ce que j'ai
vu et entendu dans le débat public et
j'aurais l'occasion de le dire le moment
venu euh il m'a pas semblé qu'on mettait
toujours le projecteur au bon endroit
sur sur ces questions vous aurez compris
que c'est que c'est mon point de vue et
que souvent on met le projecteur là où
c'est plus facile de de le mettre euh
notamment quand les gens peuvent
difficilement se défendre ou quand il y
a une forme d'habitude à à mettre le
projecteur toujours au même endroit mais
la clé est peut-être pas sous le
réverbère euh je tiens je tiens à le
dire
euh le par rapport à ce qu'a dit
monsieur le sénateur Brisson alors sur
certains points j'ai répondu par
anticipation mais pas sur tous sur le
conseil
de alors donc j'ai répondu sur la
question du du pas de vague je crois
autant que possible sur sur la question
de de du conseil des sages de la lécité
al je voudrais pas
être comme vous le voyez je n'interviens
pas tellement dans la vie publique un
tout petit peu ces derniers temps euh et
peut-être davantage dans le futur mais
en tout cas la la je me suis astreint à
ne pas émettre de de de de jugement je
me semble que c'est un devoir qu'on a à
forceorie dans cette fonction là et donc
je je souhaite pas commenter le le
détail mais en tout cas je peux dire que
j'ai pleine confiance évidemment dans la
présidente que que j'avais nommé madame
Schnapper qui est une personne de très
haute valeur et que je ne doute pas
qu'elle sache faire vivre la diversité
des points de vue pour arriver à des
résultats euh dialecties mais
complètement conformes aux enjeux de de
la laïcité et des valeurs de la
République et et quand si on juge
l'arbre à ses fruits je ne vois que des
bons fruits dans dans ce que j'ai pu
voir de la part du Conseil des Sages de
de la laïicité et j'aurais tendance à
dire que c'est très important aussi bien
sur le plan pédagogique de d'utiliser le
Conseil scientifique de l'éducation
nationale que sur le plan des valeurs de
la République d'utiliser davantage le
Conseil des Sages de la licité ce qui
que c'est ce sont des institutions qui
se sont légitimées au fil du temps qui
sont absolument pas univoques d'ailleurs
qui ont heureusement beaucoup de débat
en leur sein et mais avec des personnes
très respectables et donc on a un grand
intérêt justement pour être dans cette
logique de long terme de l'éducation
nationale pour objectiver au maximum
pour aussi parfois un peu dépolitiser
dépassionner les les les débats qui ont
besoin de une sérénité républicaine et
ben de de compter beaucoup sur ces sur
sur ces instances tout en maintenant
évidemment le le à la fin le dernier mot
l'autorité politique mais euh mais ces
deux ces deux conseils ont ont une très
grande utilité et je reste confiant dans
cette utilité euh sur la formation des
professeurs euh ben donc je l'avais un
peu abordé dans mon introduction mais on
n'inistera jamais trop là-dessus alors
il y avait des éléments dans la question
du sénateur Brisson supplémentaire par
rapport à ce que j'ai dit notamment
l'interrogation euh savoir si finalement
l'UC ucation nationale devrait pas
récupérer le l'entièreté du de la
maîtrise de cela j'ai toujours été assez
enclin aller dans cette direction et
vous le savez c'est-à-dire euh là aussi
je voudrais pas faire monre d'une trop
grande nostalgie de la 3e république
aujourd'hui c'est circonstances m on
amené mais la le fait est que l'école de
la République s'est construite par les
écoles normales et que et que il y avait
quelque chose de très intégré qui
fonctionnait bien euh le comment
dirais-je le l'esprit du temps que l'on
peut comprendre à conduit à
l'universitarisation de la de la
formation des professeurs pourquoi pas
mais là aussi il faut juger l'arbre à
ses fruits et et moi je suis pas du tout
hostile par principe à
l'universitarisation parce que j'ai une
très haute idée de l'université et du
fait que oui c'est là qu' a lieu le les
le savoir se se crée et se diffuse et on
pense en particulier pour le second
degré que il est évident qu'il faut
brancher la formation d'un d'un
professeur à ce que la recherche du plus
haut niveau peut dire sur les sujets qui
sont qui sont les siens on imagine pas
un futur professeur dans le domaine
scientifique par exemple ne pas être au
courant de tout ce qui se joue dans sa
discipline comme comme progrès donc on
ne doit pas créer un isolat c'est c'est
une évidence mais par contre il me
semble qu'au sein de l'université la
logique d'avoir une véritable école hein
c'est pour ça que on a parlé d'institut
nationaux supérieurs euh du professeur
de du professorat parce que de
l'éducation en créant les ins enfin
faisant évoluer les les ESP en insp pour
bien signifier que c'était des instituts
nationaux même s'ils étaient locaux par
leur intégration dans l'université ils
avaient une référence nationale avec des
cahiers des charges nationaux je vais
pas rentrer dans tous les détails mais
euh c'est ainsi qu'on a mis dans ce
cahier des charges le fait qu'il y avait
euh euh un un temps euh garanti sur les
savoirs fondamentaux euh qu'au moins la
moitié du temps des futurs professeurs
des écoles de devait consacré au savoirs
fondamentaux et et toute une série de
mesures y compris d'ailleurs pour
l'enseignement de de de la laïcité mais
en tout cas je pense que il faut tout
simplement piloter ce sujet en fonction
de ce que l'on constate des compétences
concrètes des futurs professeurs à la
sortie du système et je je suis je
seraiis pour ma part favorable à de
nouvelles évolutions je rappelle qu'il y
en a eu qui a eu deux évolutions
importantes quand même en la matière
donc la première c'est la création des
inspay avec le genre de mesure que je
que je viens de dire mais c'était ce
sont pas les seuls pour garantir une
sorte de qualité homogène sur l'ensemble
du pays de de la
formation en second lieu il y a eu la
création de d'une institution dont on a
auquel on n pas beaucoup prêté attention
mais qui a une logique dans la durée qui
est la création des
parcours professionnels de professeurat
des écoles les pppe qui sont en fait des
classes préparatoirees qui concerne
maintenant quelques milliers de de de
jeunes c'est-à-dire des cl classe que
l'on fait après le baccalauréat pour se
destiner aux professeurat des écoles et
pendant les trois premières années on a
à la fois des professeurs de classe
prépa et des professeurs d'université
qui viennent avec là aussi l'essentiel
du temps sur français mathématique et et
évidemment un temps qui est dédié aussi
à la à la à la la cité aux valeurs de la
République cela va nous donner dans les
temps à venir là on est dans la 3e année
du dispositif mais à partir de de dans 2
ans si je puux dire la on aura euh alors
les premières générations euh de de
jeunes professeurs qui n'auront pas
dédié 2 années à se spécialiser au
professeur des écoles mais cinq et qui
et qui auront eu une formation très
solide en en savoirs fondamentaux et en
valeur de la République on peut en
attendre beaucoup et pour pour répondre
aussi complètement que possible à votre
question je suis évidemment pour ma part
très favorable à ce que ce système
devienne non pas une forte minorité
comme c'est le cas actuellement des des
futurs professeurs mais le le le le la
référence
euh je ne doute enfin je je pense qu'il
est vraisemblable que les choses aillent
dans cette direction dans les temps à
venir évidemment ça ne m'appartient pas
aujourd'hui
euh le sur les questions de madame la
sénatrice de Marco donc j'ai répondu
autant que je le pouvais sur le sur le
rapport euh
oui donc voilà je je vraiment je
pourrais en dire plus mais je je je le
diraiis ultérieurement mais vraiment si
j'ai une chose à dire je je veux quand
même la répéter c'est que tous les
témoignages toutes les
euh tous les rapports que l'on voudra
puisse compléter ce qui a été fait euh
et et et c'est ainsi que on en aura le
le le cœur net mais je n'ai pas de
raison de
douter j'ai j'ai on peut évidemment
pointer des incomplétude euh puisquil à
la fois les avantages et les
inconvénients d'avoir été rapides
souvent on reproche au rapport d'arriver
après longtemps après cette fois-ci
celui-ci a été a été réactif et a permis
de recueillir à chaud des des
témoignages euh mais c'est les
inspecteurs généraux qui l'ont mené
eux-mêmes qui devraient
d'ailleurs répondre à ce type de de
questionnement je suis certain qu'ils
peuvent le faire j'avais répondu donc
aux questions du sénateur Alain
CADC monsieur le ministre c'est Monsieur
laleec pardon excusez-moi excusez-moi
excusez-moi mais ça reste de consonance
bretonne je suis d'accord
pardon monsieur le sénateur on parlé
Bretagne avant ça m'a ça m'a ça m'a
troublé donc j'ai répondu sur la
protection fonctionnelle et merci pour
vos réflexions liminires aussi sur
l'éducation nationale je crois que c'est
très important parce que le le le sur
l'ensemble des sujets dont nous
parlons l'éducation
nationale vit dans une société comme
elle est et cette société a tance à à
lui demander
beaucoup et souvent trop et et on doit
c'est un peu comme les théories de la
séparation des pouvoirs mais il faut
savoir à la fois distinguer et et
réfléchir au liens éducation nationale
société éducation nationale reste des
institutions et il faut essayer de ne
pas mettre l'éducation nationale en
situation défensive d'abord dans le
débat publicù c'est tellement facile de
toujours critiquer l'éducation nationale
et où pour 12 millions d'élèves il se
passe forcément des choses négatives
chaque jour que l'on peut bien sûr
pointer et auquel il faut remédier mais
il faut aussi savoir parler des trains
qui arrivent à l'heure des
établissements qui vont bien des
professeurs qui font bien leur travail
le regardez le profil des deux
professeurs qui ont été assassinés
regarde c'est des personnes qui
faisaient pas parler d'elles quand et
quand on est amené à regarder leur vie
leur biographie ce qu'ils étaient
c'était tout simplement des des gens
remarquables tout simplement euh voilà
h le sur la et donc pardon pour terminer
sur ce point
euh la la si on veut le progrès de
l'éducation nationale il faut aimer
l'éducation nationale voilà je veux dire
ça tout simplement et c'est
transpartisant c'est-à-dire que il faut
ne pas tout lui demander et s'agissant
de ses imperfections B travailler avec
l'Éducation nationale pour pour y
remédier c'est donc les sociétés qui
vont bien je je le rediraai toujours
sont les sociétés qui font confiance
dans dans dans dans leur dans leur
système éducatif et et je voudrais qu'on
arrive à sortir de la de la mode qui
consiste à à donner un coup de pied
permanent à à cette à cette belle maison
euh sur
donc les questions sur la protection
fonctionnelle donc j'ai répondu le
un le devoir pour tous les
fonctionnaires de respecter la laïcité
oui madame la sénatrice je donc je oui
je vous avais répondu par anticipation
et comment redresser la barre en matière
de de laïcité bah je voudrais oui
revenir est parti je crois
le ah d'accord euh
le je voudrais redire tout simplement à
votre suite et comme j'ai commencé à le
dire tout à l'heure que ce qui est
essentiel c'est la continuité il faut en
appeler aussi à autant que possible à
des accords aussi consensuel aussi
unanime que possible de la
représentation nationale et plus
généralement des Français euh sur la sur
une politique publique de la laïité pour
ma part j'avis j'ai toujours eu la
conviction et je l'ai encore qu'en
réalité 80 à 0 % des Français euh
pensent à peu près la même chose sur le
sujet en revanche en terme de présence
médiatique euh ça proportion va presque
s'inverser en tout cas elle elle ne va
plus être de cet ordre-là ce qui fait
que ça crée un sentiment
euh totalement irroné de de de
domination des idées antilaïques euh
alors même que
avec une sorte de sérénité on
doit montrer un consensus républicain
autour de de questions de base en
matière de laïité et qu'ensuite on ne
doit pas en dévier euh d'où l'importance
d'institution qui qui sont dans la durée
et les ministres par définition le sont
moins et donc l'importance du Conseil
des Sages de de la de la laïcité
euh qui qui désormais est quand même le
l'institution de référence en matière de
laïité dans l'appareil détail il a pas
d'autrre et et donc elle peut être
utilisée aussi pour comme point de
repère pour par exemple ce qu'on peut
dire sur les fonctionnaires en dehors de
de l'éducation nationale
euh sur ce qu'a dit donc la Catrice
Gatel j'avais répondu par anticipation
je crois qu'il faut avoir une politique
de la laïcité envers la jeunesse je
rappelle qu'on a fait une campagne de
publicité c'est la première fois que ça
existait pour la laïcité à direction des
jeunes en septembre 2021 euh que cette
campagne illustre parfaitement ce que
j'ai dit juste avant c'est-à-dire que en
réalité elle correspond je pense à ce
que l'immense majorité des Français
pensent c'estàd que la laïité c'est ce
qui nous permet de vivre fraternellement
ensemble mais que de dire des choses
pareilles aujourd'hui fait l'objet de la
part du petit 10 % activiste des choses
insensé euh pour critiquer la laïcité et
et essayer de lui donner des des coups
de bouttoir euh mais en tout cas je
crois que cette campagne était typique
de ce qu'on doit faire c'est-à-dire
aller vers la jeunesse vers les thèmes
qui lui vont raisonner par avec elle sur
les objectifs que l'on vise qui sont des
objectifs de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité et faire comprendre que la
lacité et la voix
euh vous me permettrez de faire une
incise pour dire que j'ai eu la
l'honneur d'aller au au la partie
syrienne du Kurdistan récemment euh dans
une société qui a réussi à s'organiser
euh qui a fondamentalement une société
dont la plupart des membres sont
musulmans mais où la laïcité est un
principe tout à fait naturel euh et euh
et qui montre la possibilité que enfin
qui illustre le fait ici comme dans pas
mal d'endroits que les principes
républicains ne sont pas l'apanage de la
France qu' y a des choses assez
naturelles dans le fait de penser que
Ben qu'il est bon d'avoir une forme de
neutralité du service public qu'il est
bon de d'éviter le prosélitisme à
l'école des choses euh de base qui ne
sont pas la panage des Français et qui
ne sont pas une espèce de de théorie
d'un d'un village gaulois qui ser rit
tréciré mais au contraire d'une idée
très moderne et très valable euh dans
dans beaucoup d'endroits enfin euh
s'agissant de de de vos questions
monsieur le Président la fond
euh
je il y a la question du flou éventuel
dans les normes
euh vraiment je le redis la création du
Conseil des Sages est faite pour éviter
tout flou donc je ne dis pas qu'il
n'existe pas du flou mais quand il en
existe alors euh euh il faut
immédiatement saisir le le conseil pour
sortir du flou c'est vraiment fait pour
ça euh et il a chaque fois qu'il a été
saisi pour cela il a rendu des avis des
des des avis pertinents
euh le
oui je je même depuis que je ne suis
plus ministre il y a des il y aurait des
exemples de de ça il faut ensuite que
ces avis pertinents soient mis en en en
œuvre euh et puis sur la question des
sorties scolaires qui est un un sujet
euh compliqué le ma position je crois
est assez connue mais le mais je crois
pas qu'il faille en faire un sujet
central sur la question de la laïcité
parce que justement on doit rechercher
aujourd'hui une forme de d'unité sur ces
questions et que dans la vie courante
des établissements c'est pas le sujet le
plus important
maintenant j'ai toujours considéré
que à partir du moment où on accompagné
là des enfants on était des et que c'est
pas un sujet législatif d'ailleurs c'est
presque un sujet
jurisprudentiel mais on est
collaborateur bénévoolle du service
public c'est en tout cas ma conviction
et que à partir de là on a les droits et
devoir qu'il a faire si on accompagne
des enfants et que par exemple on a un
accident dans ce cadrel et bien on aura
droit à la protection de l'État et à des
indemnisation de la part de l'État en
tant que que collaborateurs bénévoles du
service public euh et ben il me semble
je sais bien que je peux là c'est un peu
plus le professeur de droit qui parle et
qui éventuellement peut être en
contradiction avec certaines certains
avis récents du Conseil d'État mais
c'est c'est néanmoins la pensée logique
qui est la mienne je euh je ne pense pas
qu'il faille en faire un sujet
législatif dans les temps qui
viennent là cette fois par contre je dis
pour des raisons
euh politiques pour viser des objectifs
d'efficacité sur sur ces questions et ne
pas se tromper de d'objet important sur
la question de de la
laïcité merci monsieur le ministre mais
il reste une question que Madame
jacquelineage brigot veut poser a 2
minutes au chronomètre ouis c'est pas
une question c'est une réflexion
monsieur ministre je connais et on a
souvent échangé pendant la durée de
votre de votre mandat au ministère sur
la laïcité sur les valeurs de la
République bi aujourd'hui nous sommes
réunis là dans le cadre effectivement
quand même de l'assassinat
de Samuel Patti
euh certains ont écrit dans différents
livres que c'était la chronique d'une
mort annoncée parce qu'on voit bien ce
qui s'est passé alors j'iraiis pas
au-delà parce qu'on est effectivement
dans un moment judiciaire et évidemment
je n'irai pas c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
posé de question mais moi à la faveur de
de cette audition monsieur le ministre
il a quand même un mot qui n'a jamais
été prononcé aujourd'hui dans cette
audition et je vais le faire l'islamisme
tue l'islamisme l'islamisme égorge les
professeurs en France ça pti Dominique
Bernard l'islamisme fait reculer la
laïcité l'islamisme fait reculer la
République je pense qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire cette audition sans dire cela
parce que la remise en cause de notre
équilibre républicain si on n'arrive pas
à poser les choses si on narrive pas à
dire que cette idéologie mortifère
perturbe toutes nos relations et y
compris à l'école et partout à l'école
on n'avancera pas voilà ce que je
voulais
dire euh merci Madame la satrice euh
j'ai enfin j'aurais parfaitement pu euh
prononcer le mot islamisme et donc je le
prononce sans difficulté maintenant euh
bien sûr que euh nous avons un problème
avec l'islamisme politique je pense que
j'ai passé 5 ans à le dire euh et que ça
n'a pas été sans coût euh pour votre
serviteur merci monsieur le ministre
pour euh ces réponses précises que que
vous avez apporté à nos interrogations
sur ce sujet euh qui est au cœur bien
sûr de notre réflexion et dont on sait
qu'il vous anime et vous l'avez rappelé
depuis de nombreuses années merci
beaucoup